hey everyone this is Steve uh with
collider and we are here at our Sundance
studio uh I want to give a huge thank
you to filo uh they are our Sundance
sponsor and I'm sincerely grateful it
really costs a lot of money to be here
and to put on a studio to Champion indie
films I'm really grateful to them for
being our partner and um film. iio is
where you can go to get more information
about them but they're shattering the
barriers for people to Greenlight films
uh by putting the the the creation in
the hands of creators and fans uh you
can learn a lot about them by going to
the website but I'm really sincerely
grateful because yeah you could you know
anyway jumping in uh I am here with the
lovely folks behind Thelma and uh this
is one of my favorite films that I saw
so far at the Fest I just want to say
congrats to you guys for such a well
done job um so I have to I have to start
with you June um this is your you've
been acting I believe for seven decades
and I believe this is your first
starring role and I just want to know
what does it mean to you to be the lead
in this film and to have it be like such
a good movie you know what I mean
everything about it it's exciting it's
wonderful and and it's funny because I
never think of it like a leading role I
mean I I choose my roles from the script
and what the role is and I've had some
wonderful supporting role so it it's
it's just a great role I don't know who
wants to say it but everyone watching
this interview will not have seen the
movie yet so who wants to bite the
bullet and say how they've been
describing it to friends and
family in terms of the plots yeah like
the loose what it's about you do it I
know can't do it okay so
uh why why me um okay um thanks IO um
June uh plays Thelma and um Fred plays
her grandson my son and Parker Posey's
son and they're very close and
and Fred helps Danny helps her with her
Tech issues sometimes as the world
evolves very quickly for some of us in
the older generations and then um she
gets a call that Fred it's going to have
problems that Danny's been in this
terrible accident and he's hit a
pregnant lady and that he's in jail and
he's going to go into the system if she
doesn't get $10,000 cash to this lawyer
very quickly and she can't reach anybody
she can't reach she can't reach um
Parker and so she uh sends off this cash
that she's gathered from all around her
house and when we all gather we realized
it's been a scam and there's a fair
amount of um parental abuse to to Dany
for being asleep still at 10:30 in the
morning um because that's a whole
subplot of a failure to launch thing and
um but when we start to have this
conversation about maybe she's not
really able to live a alone anymore and
she can't take care of herself anymore
for my money it awakens a beast it
awakens an unlikely action star and she
decides to go get her money back yeah
this this really is like uh it's your
act it's a it's really your action movie
and um when you saw the script if like
there's a few scenes where um I think
you're being asked to go on the like
you're being asked to move a little bit
I did it exactly and so I wanted to know
like was were you nervous about doing
your own stunts Tom Cruz loved it I I
pushed it you might say really yeah no I
I I've always been physical I danced for
years and so I mean you know I felt I
could still use my body and uh I did and
then driving the scooter that was great
fun that was great fun what one of the
things about the film is you got to have
some clips of Tom Cruz and Tom Cruz is a
as a plot point um and I really was like
I can't June this is jun's Tom Cruz
movie this is this is her Mission
Impossible yeah you know it is yeah and
they they you know they gave us the okay
to use the clips so they were th they
were they like the idea too Tom has been
reaching out about being involved in the
sequel yes listen you can't you can't go
wrong when you have Tom running in a
movie so this is just another film he's
running in yeah you know um but one of
the things is you guys have some greaten
together and especially like I love the
way you're trying to explain in the
beginning of the film what how to use
the computer uh and I've had that exact
conversation with some of my older
relatives so can you sort of talk about
like just getting to work together those
scenes and how much fun you were having
okay was very um natural we we we met
beforehand um and I got to come over to
your place and hang and we started
reading the script together and um you
know when a script is this great you you
kind of uh you every scene is pretty
special and so I I definitely had that
feeling um where we just enjoyed running
through all of them and then every time
you know it was the day to do it it
would be it's exciting but then you're
also like oh I really love that scene
and now it's I'd like to do it you know
you just you really enjoy it and so we
had a really good time um there and and
and since um I did want to say though to
the to the other question the earlier
one about like how you know what
is the other idea behind the movie
because uh you know our director Josh
margan um writer director and editor uh
his real grandmother Thelma post who's
103 years old um is the basis for June's
character and I'm sort of the basis for
Josh's um and uh his his real
grandmother was almost the victim of a
phone scam similar like like this and so
he sort of imagined if she was what
would what would she do and in his
experience and my experiencing and all
of our experiences um a lot of times the
most heroic and powerful people do not
get depicted on film very much and uh I
think it's very true of Josh's real
grandmother it's very true of June
herself um that that that if someone
messed with you in that way you would be
determined to figure out how to get your
money back and how to write that wrong
and um and so that that was the other
kind of jumping off point was was what
is what does that actually look like
what is what is action in all of its
fragility in all of its commitment in
all of its messiness actually look like
on screen well one of the other things I
think that resonates with people as
they're watching is that it is what what
you're depicting in this movie is
happening to so many people and it's a
very you know it's a this is very much
happening to people who don't you know
what I mean um being scammed online on
the phone text messaging I'm not sure
about you guys but I get texts all the
time with like I get texts and I get
texts and emails all the time yeah with
people looking they're just trying to
scam you it's you know and I think
that's why it resonates so much I mean I
I'm a computer person I've been doing
this since that Max first came out I
considered myself fairly Savvy and I get
some sometimes I have to reach out to a
tech a advisor or somebody this can this
also be fake and it was a lot of times
yeah it it's really uh the no matter
what you do or how you basically they're
always going to try to oneup you you
know the scammers but anyway um when you
guys were thinking about the shoot uh or
what you looked at the schedule um
especially for you what what was the day
you had circled that you were either
really excited to film something or very
nervous to film something both the uh
the C the uh cemeteries scene with Fred
I I love that scene and I loved it when
I read the script and it it just sort of
said to me this is who this woman is you
know what she's saying and the fact that
after all she'd been through she wanted
to go to the cemetery and put some
flowers on her husband's grave and uh I
I I you know it's funny because as an
actor you think oh boy I can't wait to
get into that scene but you also think
oh can I do it you know is it something
that I understand enough to really do
and but that's me with everything though
so you know every scene is kind of that
way but that that was a wonderful scene
I'm curious for all three of you oh
sorry I just want to say I agree and I I
think sometimes a great script has what
I would almost call like a Rudder scene
it's like in times of doubt you kind of
keep rereading that scene and come back
to it a bit and I felt the exact same
way um where I would reread that scene
when we were doing other scenes
sometimes and it would it would speak to
something that was churning underneath
the whole part of it such a smart scene
it was wonderful I'm a fan of all three
of you and and your work on screen and
I'm just curious say this is a
hypothetical question say you have a big
scene on a Monday something that you
know is emotional or dramatic or you
know you're going to have to pull
something out of yourself for how early
on are you actually prepping for that
scene are you doing it when you first
get the script and sort of examining how
you want to play it or is it like
especially the LA the few days leading
up to that day that you're really in
your head about it well I think I do it
from the beginning with the script with
when you first get the script and
uh I I learn by over over over and um I
I get the script that way and I think
that I I never except for something like
the cemetery scene which was so precise
and so this is what he wants out of it
um I think most of the time it all comes
that way but it's at the beginning I
mean I don't think you can wait until
the night before and and expect to
understand it that
well I feel like uh it's so dependent on
the material and a lot of
times there'll be something in a script
that just starts to live in you and from
the minute you read it especially if
it's something you're going to do it's I
never stop I wouldn't say thinking about
it but it have it have dreams about it
I've even gone I love that Los Angeles
This brilliant woman who helps you work
with dreams and kind of ask in your
dreams what what what's getting to me
about this and sometimes you get a dream
that gives you some insight and connects
you on a deeper level to it okay I sound
crazy um but but for me um the other
part of it is sometimes there's a script
where it'll just say he's emotional or
he's crying and you're kind of like why
what why from this scene what I I I must
not understand this but then what Josh
wrote is so it's so gentle and so human
and it's not trying to make you love it
it's not trying to get emotions out of
you it's just telling a story in a very
human way and in those you kind of like
I'm gonna not think about this too much
and I'm G to show up on the day and I'm
G I know that the scene has what I need
in it
um but again I I just think that what
Josh wrote one it's been one of the
things that's really lovely about
Sundance that I don't hear a lot is we
do a thing alone in a room or in a car
or you know and everyone has to be quiet
and you don't feel it connecting with
anybody but each other luckily Jos did a
thing where we had a little not even a
couple hours just reading through some
scenes with our family yeah and it did
so much to create a family Dynamic and
Parker brings so much to that her her
amazing background with all the Chris
guest movies and the way that she can
kind of make stuff just feel like it's
happening for the first time every time
and to come here and not to not know
really how an audience is going to react
to it it didn't feel to me immediately
like a lot of Sundance movies are super
dark and Moody and edgy and this has
some of that but it's different and just
the humanity of it to get to sit in an
audience and feel people connecting to
it or dealing with the life stuff that
goes on here has been really moving for
me care about something for so long you
know a group of people come together and
you're the only people in the world that
care about that thing that story and
it's and it's a it's a bizarre process
because because you're in this world and
like you know we're
all bringing our dreams to it our lives
talking about our experiences that's
part of what you know when you're asking
about that preparation we're all
together sharing that and you just keep
pushing it pushing it up the hill as
much as you can and if you're lucky it's
finished finished and La two nights ago
was the first time that you
can a little bit if you're lucky again
Watch other people start to care about
this thing that um you know you never
you never thought that far ahead that
that that that other people would so
it's it's it's an amazing feeling
especially I think we're all very naive
and I love it you hear the things were
saying I know I always get lost in it
happen
I might have asked you this a tiff and
but I've not asked you two this question
uh if someone you you hold on you went
to Tiff yeah with this no no no no no
yeah I did a solo I did a solo Tiff run
without you guys a covert secret
anything Fred does without me I'm a
little bit like what do you mean dude I
was
free uh you you guys have great resumés
and I'm curious and you can answer this
again but if someone has never seen
anything you've done before outside of
Thelma what is the because you can
easily say Thelma and it's fantastic uh
what would you recommend they watch
first and
why you want me to yeah
Nebraska that was again a joy to make
and the people involved and uh it it was
just a wonderful experience and then we
went through the whole award season
together so we had about three years
together in all Fant fantastic film if
you've never seen Nebraska strong
recommendation fantastic I would I'm I'm
going to answer this in a sec but um I I
love all of Dreams movies I've seen but
I wish I had a a time machine because I
also wish I could have when we were
going through all the pictures I wish I
could have seen the the old plays and
the musicals too those are the things
those are things I'm always kicking
myself because when it's something
that's you know doesn't exist on film
you're like oh my gosh if only I was
there um let me see well
uh I did a short film called David um
that I'm deeply proud of um okay because
I'm at Sundance the first thing I came
here was a with was a movie called The
Adventures of Sebastian Cole and I
played an ex-marine who was very
clumsily trying to transition in late
90s um late 90s Upstate New York and it
was a first feature by this wonderful
guy Kip Warden I don't know I just
except for how badly I walked in the
heels I really I'm proud of that movie
what is the most nervous you've been the
night before the first day of filming
something my first
film it scared me to death I I you know
I'd worked so much on stage but I'd
never done film and I was doing Woody
Allen's Alice and he was wonderful
wonderful to me and it was a great
experience but boy was I scared before I
ever walked on to that set and I mean
this woman has a resume on Broadway
that's Titanic yeah but you step into
the different medium and it's terrifying
because it's completely different yeah
is it is it one of those things where
where the night before you're just not
sleeping are you that much in your head
or you yeah I mean you know you you're
thinking about it so much and it's so
important to you and you have no I had
no idea what to do it was so because I
could still remember that all of the
crew were trying to keep me away from
the cables I didn't know about cables
backstage getting to the set and they
were all and I I felt like if they could
have they would have carried me in just
to get me away from all the cables found
I remember I found the lingo so
confusing because um there's that turn
of phrase that they say on set where
they you know setting up they're
rehearsing a scene and they say and
we'll figure this shot this part out of
the camera on the day they say on the
day and I remember doing a scene and
being like I thought we were doing the
scene today like when when what is this
a next week scene and if not what are we
doing right now it was like
terrifying um
I I feel like it happens every time I
felt all those same ways like I don't
understand where the camera is or what I
should be doing and I think all the
stuff I did first you see me looking to
see where the little Mark on the floor
is a lot um but even after I had done
some stuff the day I was showing up for
the first scene in The Avengers and it
was going to be this group of actors
that I was in awe of I was like I'm
afraid I'm not I'm going to open my
mouth and nothing's going to come out
we're almost out of time but I I want to
um uh film EO uh is about putting the
I'm bringing our sponsor back into this
is all about putting who's the sponsor
again right exactly is it film eio is it
eio it's not IO it's film. IO fil
website they provided wonderful snacks
here only was written on a cup right
exactly there was only a cup that we
could
listen I I really am grateful but filo
is is I'm reading this just to make sure
I say it right is all about putting the
power to greenl films in the hand of
creators to lean into that a little bit
uh can you each name someone who
empowered you on a past project someone
who believed in you and put the creative
power in you when when you didn't really
didn't expect to get
it good question Frosty
lives you got to answer this though
sir
I mean I I'm sorry I'm like hundreds of
names are rattling through my mind
because I'm realizing that that my whole
love of independent film and my
experience with being an actor is just
is just literally I'm not even being
hyperbolic literally hundreds and
hundreds of of of people who are so
willing and open to field every question
and and go beyond I mean from that's not
just directors that's entire that's the
entirety of the crew like I'm always
quite Amazed by by um how gracious every
crew is in terms of Illuminating you
know exactly how they do something if
you go up and you say wait a second why
is that this this and this and they tell
you exactly
um uh yeah I'm thinking of I'm thinking
of a great uh sound designer that worked
with John pritchet who let me um maybe I
love John an amazing amazing person and
did so many of my favorite films and I I
I was doing a Western in in New Mexico
and and he would let me sit in the sound
truck with him and all of his guys and
would basically teach me um uh just beat
by beat how how how is he recording five
pieces of audio right now because the
way that they had they set it up is he
wanted this kind of documentary um film
making so you're recording all these
tracks at the same time and exactly how
is he doing that how is he keeping that
there and anyways I just I remember
feeling like this is a master class um
from one of you know our great sound
designers so yeah he's done more amazing
movies and this guy there's none of them
I could even say has the best stories of
anybody in the business the stuff he's
heard over the little microphones that
are on your body all day oh dear Lord
and he'll tell you um so much of the
time this maybe sound naive like you
kind of feel like you're
just we saw the Sasquatch movie last
night you're a little Sasquatch trying
to get through the woods on your own and
when somebody T says like oh no I really
love what you're doing I really want to
I want you to come into this it just
gives you another 10 years of life I
think it's just it's so empowering I had
an acting class in NYU and the two
teachers were young playwright named
David mammo and his main guy who just
come to sh from Chicago with him William
H Macy and we studied together for a
couple years we formed a theater company
and then mammed offered me my first bit
roll in a movie which I was like oh he's
backing it up and then mammo I mean Macy
directed A play in New York a one act on
42nd Street and he gave me a nice part
in that and I went wow that's that's
real well I have to say my husband
Charles kakat sakas was a an acting
teacher and we met acting in stock and I
was brought in to do the
musicals and we became together we we
lived together and he he always said to
me you're you're fine in musicals you're
great in musicals but you really should
be acting and so he literally changed my
life I mean he he uh he made me do it he
made me learn how to work and and uh so
I I was this was the biggest thing ever
happened in my life because I wouldn't
be doing what I'm doing now if it
weren't for him I definitely Fred I have
to ask you an individual question
because I'm a big fan of Kyle Mooney and
um I believe you're in Y2K which is his
next film or am I wrong about this I
want to break any news but I I'm not
because it's all it was I was going to
do a very funny Cameo thing in that but
then um you got like two or three other
huge movies no it's just yeah we anyways
but it's gonna be great sure I guess
I'll switch to something else and just
say um because I know you can't talk
about Gladiator and anything specific
but I'm going to ask you're in
Gladiator
just one of the things though is you you
got to work with Ridley and the thing
that I found fascinating about Ridley is
he works in such a different manner than
other filmmakers because he shoots with
six or eight cameras at all the all the
time so you're like at lunch you've shot
your whatever you need to shoot you know
and then he works very fast so as an
actor what is it like working when
you're shooting with six or eight
cameras and can you sort of talk about
you know being making Gladiator with
Ridley working in that such a different
environment it's amazing I mean the the
the eight cameras reminds me of theater
because you have an entire environment
that's created in camera and it's but I
have to say what's amazing too is when
something feels
alive it feels alive in in unique but
connected ways so um when something's
really special you know what we're doing
here it's like when you when you start
to find a
rhythm I I
feel if again if I'm lucky I feel
connected to that feeling of when I
start doing plays and and what is that I
can't even I could never been able to
put a name on whatever that weird
feeling is but you just you just get a
sense of it and I hope they're getting
this yeah yeah yeah yeah I hope they're
rolling no that like that that there's
that there's something that you can't
put your finger on that's within the
moment of the moment in the moment and
like you know we spend all this time
hanging out and you know it's like first
off you make real friends which is an
amazing part and then you also within
the scenes you you find something thing
that's just um that that you cannot name
and and uh all the intensity of of that
set breeds that and all the kind of
gentleness of this one breeds that and
they all kind of I always find that the
process becomes the product and so um
however it's designed is is built to to
to bring out and and nurture and kind of
speak to that story that it's trying to
tell on that note I just want to say a
sincere congratulations to all three of
you for making such a fantastic film I
know everyone's going to love it who
sees it I wish you guys nothing but the
best and I also want to give a huge
thank you one last time to filo for
being our sponsor and supporting Indie
cinema at Sundance look for more
interviews thank you so much for having
us and again thank you so much filo for
having us yeah um thank you and you guys
have a fantastic Sundance thank you so
much